but yeah welcome to everybody let's try
it Isabelle I haven't used her at all I
want to preface that when people are
like dude this guy's not even using the
best move it's not using the best move
he doesn't know how to play this
character you're right I don't
so we're all learning together here okay
this the theme is for this one is Best
in Show and we've got a height for
animal crossing villagers okay Isabelle
has a lot of like different tools at her
disposal from what I've seen like when
I've been watching other people using
her okay yeah there's that attack right
there
see if I can see if I can even get on
the ground to do this attack she plants
like one of those little uh oh come on I
can't get it planted one of those little
things from Animal Crossing I think
they're called guy rides keloid he would
I don't know how you say it but then if
somebody walks over that
I mean apparently the crowds enjoying it
even though I'm getting annihilated
they're chanting they're chanting for
Isabelle right now Oh a Smash Ball would
be nice this is just oh okay just non
Smash Ball off reappeared and now the
villager has an ultimate and I have 166
damage I dodged it Oh harsh side retro
rag into a radio that must mean har site
is still waiting to get his internet set
up guys in his new place okay just let
me figure out the most here people all
these sweet friendly looking villagers
wanting nothing more than to just
annihilate me from the stage right now I
have a hundred and ninety-nine that
might be it come on use the pokeball I
gotta pull this off for you guys I gotta
pull this off
there we go knock them off knock them
off at least they're playing pretty
passively I don't want to go near that
spike because like any hit right now is
gonna send me flying no no no no no
we've come this far we've come this far
no no don't grab that
please fall off I just want to learn
Isabelle's moves there we go that should
do it
that should do it with 211 percent two
hundred and eleven percent we get the
victory over
was it three no for animal crossing
villagers are sites still learning by
listening didn't hook up your internet
this morning oh man I told you dude we
were talking about I'm not gonna name
him on stream you're talking about this
company the other day horse side and I I
think that's like all Internet companies
though right I feel like oh wow we got a
point one increase for that very nice
very nice I feel like you hear so many
stories about that Internet companies
like not not showing up when they're
supposed to not setting things up
properly all right so that's the down
beat watch that see that little guy that
launched over there but somehow the Wii
Fit trainer just totally bypassed it
okay forward B is the infamous fishing
pole which has been used on me one too
many times like the range on this thing
is ridiculous you can use it to grab
items and as you just saw there look
look at look how long that is look at
that dude and then as soon as they like
step on it come on come on look at that
just pull Pikachu in from that far away
her smash attack feels a little weak oh
gosh
the little tilt was the umbrella so that
was pretty cool that was a lot quicker
to come out than the smash attack I'm
trying to see what she's actually using
on the smash attack something like looks
like one of those little poppers like
one of those little birthday like
confetti or comes out of it I think see
if we can tell here dude is every one of
them gonna be against like teams yeah
that's what it is it's one of those
little party poppers oh they're fighting
each other okay go ahead I'll just I'll
just chill right over here
talk to the stream guys talk to the
stream long you all fight over there you
know what we're just gonna use the
fishing pole wait wait for it wait for
it then hook them right in throw mom
that's not even her grab move guys
that's not the grab moon had a Comcast
worker once who is confused why my modem
wasn't giving a watch to explain him it
wasn't a router oh man that's exactly it
though dude it's exactly what I'm
talking about so many stories like that
I will say like four negatives on Isabel
so far
she is very floaty you get up in the air
oh yeah that was her forward hey what is
her - she throws a little pot
and that little X breaking pot is very
powerful the guy this morning was very
nice problem is deciding who should
drill and bring the COEX into your
apartment the hard side that's what I
was telling you dude
that is the exact exact situation I was
having man I just wanted them to move
mine and they kept telling me oh we
can't do that the laws here prevent us
you have to get an electrician whenever
I talk to people by phone
I guess maybe their corporate office or
whatever they're always like oh yeah no
problem no problem
oh yeah we do that all the time we'll
take care of it then they show up nope
nope so finally I begged my sweet and
wonderful wife
let me change change my streaming room
it's where the modem and Internet was
already set up where we had the outlet
here it took it took some persuading and
begging my son to let me move his
playroom my four-year-old son but
finally we got it done
I mean it is chaos right now but yeah
Hearthside sounds like you're having a
very similar runaround
that I was getting how do you have a
hundred and one I don't feel like I've
even fighting you guys that much whoa I
do not want to take a hit right now what
does that move her her neutral B attack
she puts out this little pinwheel of
light okay relax they're all coming
after me cuz they sense a weak one you
see oh he's at 154 no no by each other
whomp-whomp there we go I think Isabel's
gonna be really fun once I learned her
but right now it's see if we can get him
with this
oh dude so I just used it right there Oh
like picks up items and then she like
put him in her pocket watch this oh that
time it didn't work maybe you can only
pick it up once okay see I just put push
beyond that item she put in her pocket
now let's push me again and then she
pulls it out so what if you play with no
items what can you do with it can I like
actually grab you
no you can't okay see it's not doing
anything to the ice climbers but you
know what I bet you can use it on
projectiles imagine I wonder if you can
use it on rockets and samus's charge
beam that'd be pretty cool if you can
use it on things like that I can
definitely see the usefulness even if
you're playing without items our side
says it'll be gravy soon just hope for
Christmas not holding your breath
oh man that's right got the holidays
around the corner so you know it's even
more if like they're probably saying if
we could just if we can just get to the
holidays
boom hello Daisy
right on the screen there that's right
Rosalina's in this game I don't have her
unlocked yet either yeah I feel like the
key to using Isabel is gonna be figuring
out how to use all of her like kind of
unique attributes like I feel like she's
more unique than a lot of characters
because of the fact that I mean you have
this fishing pole that grabs yet it's
not a grab move you can literally just
grab items and store them for later I
don't know that there's another
character like that where you can I'm
assuming it'll even work on projectiles
like I'm thinking Lynx bombs samus's
rockets arrows from characters maybe
even Bayonetta's I don't know about
bullets Solid Snake's rockets
[Music]
yes see that's it right there
me and that move when you get hit by it
is devastating trying to get familiar
with her up attacks here all the turnips
man if you've ever played Animal
Crossing you got to remember the turnips
that is her up when you're in the air up
attack oh gosh I forgot about that
that's her grab right there the net is
actually the grab it's gonna try to just
hang the gosh how long is that fire last
oh I thought she was over my net or a
fishing pole there no no whoa what even
hit her oh that baseball nice very nice
indeed all right we're up to 7.3 I think
we're near the end here now I think it's
time for the yeah the bonus game and
then the final boss all right here's my
here's my hope for this final boss I
don't want to spoil it if you guys
haven't seen the other ones so I'm not
gonna say who they are but just know
that there are some amazing final bosses
in this game that are I mean I didn't
read a lot of spoilers maybe it was
revealed before launch but I had no idea
about a lot of these okay can we attack
in midair please can we can we not oh
okay I guess yes we're not going to
attack there we go all right finally
that was very strange I didn't know
about a lot of these bosses but not
every character has them a lot of
characters you still fight mastery and
crazy and the traditional Smash Brothers
bosses we've all come to know and love
maybe and so now I've kind of set myself
up for disappointment because on every
character I'm hoping hoping for a secret
boss so for Isabelle if I had to pick
one I would say I would say mr. Resetti
for any of you Animal Crossing folks out
there hopefully you remember you
remember mr. Resetti because mr. Resetti
if you ever you may have you may have
played an animal crossing and never
encounter mr. Resetti
or at least never faced his wrath but if
you ever turned off your gamecube
without saving just resetting then you
would be forced to meet mr. Resetti
oh and there's the disappointment of
mastering and crazy hand come on
Nintendo should have put mr. Resetti in
as a final boss but anyway yeah he would
pop up and he would sort of uh scold you
or not saving your game because Animal
Crossing was all about like it was not
online yet it was a game that felt like
you were online it's kind of amazing how
it worked it was well ahead of its time
especially in terms of Nintendo we all
know how they've been reluctant for
online gaming man they are gonna knock
me off or sure see if I can get one
stunned that's the key to winning this
fight when you're solo don't get hit by
that
hey there see crazy head is stunned now
and I'm just gonna try and leave him see
if I can get master hands stunned as
well there we go
and I'm gonna go back and work on crazy
hand cuz he's back up basically whenever
you have one of them alone oh man I got
sucked into the void sucked into the
dock void dodged that one voice didn't
dodge that
[Music]
man I've seen people like completely
dominate with his bill I got to figure
out how to use her oh wow that knocked
me off so close to to being able to
finish it without using a life
no Dodge
[Music]
crazy and eliminated from the battle
come on master hand there we go all
right yeah I'm not really gonna be able
to fully learn all these characters till
I actually start playing them repeatedly
instead of just jumping from character
to character but I feel like honestly
one of the keys to getting good at Smash
Brothers you don't have to be good with
every character but you have to be
familiar with every character and this
is one of the reason like I've never
been one of those people this might be a
controversial thing to say I have never
been one of those people that's like
more characters more characters more
characters because the more characters
you add it becomes a lot harder to
balance for one and as a player of the
game it becomes a lot harder to sort of
play against because you have to know
every character to be like to be really
good at the game I'm talking like you
know tournament level you have to know
every single one of these characters
inside now even if you don't play as
them so that's why I'm not I'm not that
great right now with all these random
characters but it is at least exposing
me to all of them as well oh and look
who or who we're about to unlock here if
we can take him out mr. game and watch
himself
I actually not feeling that confident
about this fight because I'm not super
comfortable with Isabel yet she's so
unique she uses lots of like items and
stuff
lots of items and tools see we got we
got flowerpots here we got fishing poles
we've got Nets he's already got me to 28
or 69 73 me and that just seems like
such a weak air attack right there the
little slingshot that is a very powerful
attack right there just leave it out
there then when he gets close pull it
back in oh my gosh come on game and
watch you're better than that oh oh and
it can knock out like that dude